-Take it in, Maya! Feel it.
Do you feel the love right now?
-I feel the love!
-Maya Rudolph.
-I almost sat --
I almost sat right here.
-Yeah, you did.
We got rid of that part
of the couch.
-What happened to your couch?
Did you downsize?
-We got rid of that part --
We're downsizing here.
So, yeah, now we have -- It's
more kind of like a love seat.
-The love seat.
-Yeah.
-It's a love -- Hi, audience.
Thank you for being here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. Isn't that amazing?
-This is really nice.
It feels like --
It feels like the before times.
-It does, right?
-You remember the before time?
-I do remember the --
"The before..." Is that what you
call them? The before times?
-Yes.
-The before times, yeah.
-The before times.
-How is the family?
How is everybody?
-Everybody's great.
I brought them out for this trip
'cause we haven't been anywhere.
You know, we haven't
traveled in a year.
And my family --
Like, my kids really love
"Saturday Might Live" now.
So it's funny.
-Pearl?
-Well, Pearl,
you've known the longest
'cause I had her
when I was on the show.
But she doesn't remember.
Like, I said we were coming
to the show, and she said,
"Jimmy Fallon knows who I am?"
I was like,
"Jimmy used to hold you."
-Yeah! Pearl! I sang to you!
-This is, like, our first
real, yeah, "vacation."
-Wow.
-I know.
-Because you were
coming back and forth,
L.A. to New York,
to do Kamala Harris, which --
Congrats on the Emmy,
by the way.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you.
Yeah.
-Did you get --
Did you receive the Emmy?
'Cause I know
you didn't get one in person.
-I finally did.
It took a little while.
They were doing
some very, like,
COVID-friendly engraving,
I guess.
I guess when you go to
the Emmys and you get an Emmy,
they do it at the party
and you wait at the party.
I don't know. But, yeah,
mine was sent to my house.
And I was really excited,
and the kids were so excited,
and they opened it up,
and the first one I got
was for "Big Mouth."
And we open it up --
-That's right. Your voice.
-Yeah, but I didn't know
that it said
the name of the episode
that you're on, on the Emmy.
So I was like, "I got an Emmy.
It's got my name on it."
And it's like "Maya Rudolph"
and the episode,
"How to Have an Orgasm."
I was like, "Great."
[ Laughter ]
-Kids, uh, yeah, hi.
[ Laughs ] Wow.
There's a conversation
right there.
I wanted to ask you
because, obviously,
some way, we end up talking
about Prince on the show.
-I know. I know.
It's a staple, I think, right?
I can't, like, look across
the room at Quest and not --
It feels -- It feels right.
-Do you have --
-A lot of Prince things
happened in this building.
-Yes. That's correct.
-Yeah.
Did you have Pearl when
Prince was musical guest?
-You know what? I was on
maternity leave actually when --
I didn't know
when I was coming back,
but I was fully, like,
brand-new baby.
I think she was
about three months old.
And then I found out that Steve
Martin was going to be the host
and Prince was going to be
the musical guest.
And I was like, "I'm up."
-"I'm up."
-Got on a plane.
-"I'm up!"
-We brought Pearl.
Like, she was, like,
still a loaf of bread.
She was so small.
And we flew out here.
Brought my breast pump, like,
brought, like, everything.
I mean, you know,
when you have a brand-new baby,
it's very sexy.
-Wow. It sounds sexy, yeah.
-Yeah. No, but it --
Yeah, brought everybody.
It was really exciting.
-See Steve Martin and Prince.
-Oh, my God. I mean.
That's like a Maya Rudolph --
Baby Maya dream sandwich.
-Do you ever get
any memorabilia or any --
Do you have any Prince stuff?
Or, like, a --
-I -- I am lucky enough
that, like, now it's known
that I love Prince,
so, like,
it's not a secret anymore.
Like, everybody knows.
"Hey, you like Prince."
Like, okay, great.
And someone gave me -- A friend
of mine gave me his belly chain.
I have his belly chain.
-Wait. From the --
-From his belly.
-Yes, of course. That's where
he wore it, around his belly.
-Yeah, you know, like, yeah --
In the "Mountains" video
when he's got --
You know, when he's got the
little pants and the thing.
-And the vest?
Is that the vest look?
-Yeah, and, like,
the little good --
It's, like, the bolero jacket --
-Yes, bolero jacket.
-And the hat.
-Oh, no!
-The good meats right here.
There's a little cutout.
And there's, like,
a little gold. Yeah, that.
-You have that?
-I have it.
And I wear it around my neck
'cause it does not fit
around my waist.
-I don't know
whose waist it would fit.
I mean, Prince, I guess.
-Just one person.
-Just one human being.
That's wild.
-I take it and go like this.
[ Smooching ]
-Oh. Come on. You miss him.
I want to say congrats
because here you are
on the cover
of another magazine.
-Oh, thank you. I'm on the fold.
Yeah, look at that.
-Look at this.
This is the "Vanity Fair."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-She really got down there.
She really got down there.
-Look at this.
This is Maya Rudolph.
This is -- Oh, sorry.
-I'm known for my splits,
apparently.
-Now, I did not know
you could do a split.
-I can't.
-Okay, there you go.
-Those are not my legs.
-Those are not your legs.
Good. All right. Good.
-No, I think my dad
was like, "Wow."
Like, um...
-Yeah, Dad, no.
-I don't know
how to do the splits.
Nor did I ever know
Even when you're, like, a kid
and you just, like, drop it.
-Yeah.
-You know, kids are just like,
"Watch this. Boof."
-Yeah.
-I was not that kid.
-You were never that kid?
-I was like, "Watch this. Err."
-Ugh!
-Oi!
-"Oi."
I love just hearing your voice.
And I bring this up
because, obviously,
you won the Emmy
for "Big Mouth,"
but now you're in a new movie.
-Yeah, an animated movie.
-Perfect for you.
-Yeah.
-I love it.
-Yeah, I got to say,
I like the animated movies
also 'cause my family
genuinely enjoys them.
But, yeah, it's a movie called
"The Mitchells
Versus the Machines."
It's a kid's --
really cute family movie.
Like, weirdos --
like, a family of weirdos
that end up doing
a cross-country drive,
like, a family road trip
to take the daughter to college,
but they end up, um, uh,
saving the world.
-Yeah. Why not?
-Yeah.
-Why not?
That's April 30th on Netflix.
-Yeah.
-So check that out.
But, then, this weekend,
"Saturday Night Live."
-Yeah.
-You're back. You're home.
-I'm home. I'm home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Really, honestly, like,
it's so nice to be there.
-Yeah.
-First of all,
this building feels very good
during these strange times.
Feel very safe here.
But we were here --
You and I were here
for very strange times
in this building.
-Yeah.
-We were here
during September 11th.
We were here during the anthrax
that was in the building.
Remember that?
-I was in the build--
I actually came into work
that day.
-You brought the anthrax.
-No. I did not bring anthrax.
That is a rumor.
But I did go to Starbucks.
I came like everything
was normal.
Like, "Duh-da-da."
I got Starbucks.
-Yeah, normal day.
-I walk up to the 8th floor,
and everyone's walking around
in the hazmat suits.
And I go,
"What sketch is this?"
They're like, "Dude, you
shouldn't have been here.
You didn't check your messages
or whatever?"
I was like, "What's going on?"
-Yeah, my cousin called me
and said,
"Your building is on the news.
Are you going into work today?"
"Uh, I guess so?"
-Yeah. What bizarre times.
-Bizarre times.
But you know what?
This place that we know so well,
it's been nice to be here.
Coming back and forth
doing the show for the election
felt really nice
'cause it feels like home
and it feels like
we're doing something.
-We need entertainment.
-I know.
And you forget that, too.
You're like,
"It's just comedy."
But people do really need to
laugh. It feels really good.
-Yes! It does!
-It's been feeling good for me
to be watching the show.
Just to know that there's
people in the audience now,
it just feels really good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We're gonna get back.
We're gonna get back.
Guys, Maya Rudolph, everyone.
She's hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
this weekend with musical guest
Jack Harlow.